えっ
これじゃあねそうです
[音楽]
会え大手やろうと違う
あ
これはただのブロワーですねこれじゃなくて
[音楽]
持っていきますそれでこちら透明なテント
帰りましたこれをも佐々木みたら6数分頃って書いてあったので普通にめちゃくちゃ
重いです
テントって普通年ってあのなんかが見えないようにも用途が入るとはついてるんです
けどもこのテントな斬新の最先端テントデローム錠の透明の中よくわかんない何でスレ
を作ったって思うくらいな
そのてたんですけどもめっちゃオシャレなとこういう機会なんでそのにキャンプといけ
ないじゃないですか家のなどのベランダでいても外の景色を楽しめるまさに理想の
テントだなと思いまし私ものスケルトン伝統を買わせていただきました
という風に今から家の屋上で早速テント判定機ましょう
なくもう1回今日受けて家の屋上に行ってきましたんす
チーズの数ので選んだが近いんでちょっとあんまり大語でしゃべれないべきはおとな
しーく天つ切りさせていただきたいと思いまーこんなに広いスペースがあると多分いい
感じにね天空のつけるとテントを作れると思うんですよねは上げていきましょう
フレンドして不透明なんですこの鍵だと白いところを送っ
羅夏枚撮るだけじゃんこれ
ています
ください
良いぞ想像の何倍もデカイとこれ
何をすればいいんだいや待て本当にでかすぎて何をどうすればいいかわからんぞこれ
めっちゃでかいけど
待つ甲斐なく透明なのは確かですこのみてくださいスペース型のアイドルが着るような
謎の透け感ありますここかが空気孔違う
どっか空気れればいいかわかんないんですけどこれ説明書がなかったしてちょっと空気
出る場所を探します
なにこれこれかこれだこれだ空気ではあいにくの代わりですが空気入れていこうと思い
ますこれたぶん娘カードにロックしたんですよね空気が見えないように
よしっレディガオー
boss me
[音楽]
でこんなでかいもんなん大変だけで完成しました
脱するテントでございます本当に想像以上にでかいです
入り口でも俺並みのサイトありますからね
[音楽]
というわけで早速入ってみましょう甘すぎ星口金
池口がちょっとマジでこれだけ打線が打ってなるやつでしょこれ
[音楽]
あっはい
car
すっごくねー阿部ダメだこれもう一瞬なるがすぐ空気抜けちゃう
けどこれ2重ロックになって言ってここでさらにまたロックされてるみたいですね
the
何か入ってみましょうかでは早速何か入ってみましょう
助ける遠すぎて全然実感が湧かないんですけど
入り口がここにあるんですよ
いくぜ
それっ
[音楽]
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ta
ええええ
すごーい
すっごい2
建造たっ回数そっとこれ食べですよテントのならすげー
て結界張っているみたいと at フィールドみたいな感じこれが店頭のならござい
ますもう
えええええええええ
スターをまっすぐここでのものを2分声響くな武術と思うものとかどういったりして
ここでないかなキャンプっぽいのが出てきませんですけど
幻想的でただもでかすぎ度顕著ことがない方にから被ってる事があるん
アヴェダん
いろんな
これ
ペンとの中ですよ
いかがでしょうかなが声がすごい夢の中の恋人になってますけども
これヘッドなので室内に見えてき5回か
程度など今後にませんよあとことでこのデータん
26打点で空気が逃げにくくなってるんだと思います
すっごくいい系等々茎これ以上やることで気になってたんですけど
これでチャックがあるんですよこれは見たらどうなるんだろうだから普通に食って受け
たりするからです
誰に何か目指せ週間テンション上がるんですけども
[音楽]
ブーブー言っ
簡単とたて貼ったかちょ